you were a host did it right now  appreciate the difficulty and complexity  of my job now that you have done it  yourself I mean do you it's do you truly  understand what it takes for me day in  and day out to do this game she does  human I'm not going away  I give people this little thing at the  top she's dancing around she's cheering  for the audience so they don't really  want that  [Applause]  what's a big dumb head just sit here  with my big dumb hat hey I'm telling you  this take this took a lot of work I  gotta keep this thing large and in  charge but you must have had a good  seemed like you were having a really  good time I did had a great time